hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast introduction to exosomes and
other extracellular vesicles the body's
molecular internet for personalized and
precision medicine
I am Brenda Kelly Kim on lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
lab routes comm is the leading
scientific social networking site and we
are proud to bring you this interactive
web seminar for more information please
visit us at www.americanoutback.net
this is an educational web seminar and
so offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C e button located in the
bottom left-hand corner of your webpage
and follow the instructions to claim
your credits I would now like to
introduce today's speaker ray Magana ray
Magana is a serial entrepreneur with
over 25 years experience in life
sciences mr. McDonough is currently
co-founder of the XO incubator a life
sciences technology incubator and
accelerator XO incubators mandate is to
exploit the power of its exosome and
extracellular vesicles platform
technology to potentiate precision
medicine and address critical areas of
an unmet medical medical need among the
disease areas of interest are oncology
metabolic disease genetics immunology
and infectious disease previously he was
part of the team that pioneered
extracellular vesicle and exosome
nucleic acid technologies for
applications in molecular diagnostics
drug delivery and therapeutics he
co-founded proxy life science Holdings a
biotechnology company
organized to develop those technologies
he also co-founded Perry scientific
contract research organization
specializing in preclinical research
services supporting early-stage
pharmaceutical bio pharmaceutical and
medical device companies I will now turn
it over to Ray for his presentation
or the introduction Karen I also want to
thank lab roots for hosting this talk
good afternoon and good evening to all
attendees thank you for joining us my
talk is titled the introduction to
exosomes and extracellular vesicles
implications for personalized and
precision medicine before we begin the
talk I do want to share a disclaimer
that I am a co-founder and stockholder
and XO incubator and therefore I have an
interest in various technologies
companies and patent pools which include
the following two patents which are in
the field of exosomes solar vesicles and
nucleic acids and with that we'll get
started the discussion I've basically
broken it down into four main segments
the first will be a brief history of
exosomes and extracellular vesicles from
their origins to our current
understanding the second section will
involve it would be on the involvement
in physiology and pathology with a focus
on human disease and the third I want to
discuss why I believe there is a fertile
environment for this technology at this
time and its potential role in
personalized medicine and finally the
fourth segment will focus on practical
applications and we will talk about two
important areas their use in research
and development as a platform and also
their use for development of novel
medical diagnostics so the first section
will start with what are extracellular
vesicles and we'll cover a brief history
of their origins and our current
understanding of their functions and so
extracellular vesicles and exosomes
comprise newly discovered communication
system which we like to call the
Internet of the body and it's a very
fundamental system that affects every
cell and organ and it's believed that
every cell type produces them and today
are involved in both normal physiology
and pathology and they circulate in by
fluids and each exosome or extracellular
vesicle is representative of the cell
from which originates and we like to
call them proxies for those cells now
they they comprise an extensive network
which interconnects various biological
systems and so by collecting these
exosomes and extracellular vesicles and
interrogating their content we
essentially have a very powerful tool
that we can use to gain really
unprecedented insight into the molecular
activity and the crosstalk that is
taking place and in the future we this
may be done in in real time and and
currently it's non-invasive since it can
be obtained from biological fluids the
vesicles extrasolar vesicles are derived
from membrane-bound structures they're
released by cells into the extracellular
space and there are essentially two main
categories exosomes are released from
cells when endocytic a multi vesicular
body's fuse with the plasma membrane
where as micro vesicles are released
directly from the plasma membrane via
blooding and here's a nice example of
platelet microvesicles being released as
electron microscopy image just to give
an idea of relative size the exosomes
which are the smaller burgeoned vesicles
are in the range of viral particles
whereas microvesicles are a bit larger
and they're in the range of bacteria
apoptotic bodies which also follow in
the definition of vesicles are a bit
larger and although again they are
included in that definition for the most
part we when referring to extracellular
vesicles
they're mostly referring to exosomes and
microvesicles and we try to
differentiate that by specifically using
the terminology for one or the other but
since the beginning they've been used
interchangeably and so the reason that
exosomes and microvesicles are an
exciting entities to study and and they
have a lot of potential for applied
research and translational research and
eventually in the development of
diagnostics and therapeutics is that
they are a rich source of information
and they derive that information because
they are they carry macromolecular
cargoes in the form of proteins nucleic
acid bioactive lipids as well as
metabolites it's estimated that about 3
million means what critters can be found
in per microliter of serum and they
represent a heterogeneous population so
because these zones and microvesicles
are produced from various different cell
types they are representative
representing it in the circulation of
note these vesicles are of most interest
because they are functional in their
bioactive indeed one of the very first
experiments that led to that notion was
that people observe that these vesicles
were elevated in cancer patients as
compared to in normal patients the other
important I think property is that these
are relational data sets in a way
because they all derive within a single
exosome so you can find these
macromolecules in a single exosome
whereas other circulating proteins or
nucleic acids are usually independent
and you don't see that relational aspect
to it and so
these vesicles because of the surface
they carry a lot of surface markers that
are associated with the cells from which
they originated from they can be
identified in terms of their tissue
specific sourcing and part of the reason
that they are bioactive is that they are
rich in their cargoes and for instance
they carry many many types of membrane
proteins including oncogenes and growth
factor receptors integral receptors MHC
class 1 molecules soluble proteins such
as for the ages and cytokines as well as
signaling proteins and suppress
transcriptional regulators reverse
transcriptase and transmembrane protein
indeed out of the 14 4400 proteins that
have been identified and that number is
probably much higher now many of them
are molecular markers that are
associated with cancer for instance
those listed here in veg F for to be GFR
napkin and again these markers can also
and have been used and work has been
published where you can pull specific
populations of exosomes using using
these markers for instance using nucleic
acids have also been found including DNA
and RNA DNA there's both genomic and
complementary RNA that's been identified
and as far as RNA there's over 1,300
different molecules both coding and
regulatory EXO Carta is a very good
source it's a comprehensive database of
the various proteins and clay Cassatt
contents that are found in essence and
extracellular vesicles with regard to
RNA there's a messenger RNA non-coding
RNA and micro RNA among other species
that can be found within them one of the
first reports of these extracellular
vesicles was back in 1967
by Peter wolf and in his case he
observed them in human plasma as he was
studying platelets and coagulation and
at the time he called them platelet dust
and also they were known early on as
micro particles because they were not
well characterized at the time and you
could see actually he he also was the
first to identify that you could isolate
these using ultrasonic ocation and that
they were rich in phospholipids most
importantly one of his findings was that
that they showed coagulant properties
resembling those of platelet factor 3
and so likely factor 3 initiates the
blood coagulation cascade and he he
noticed this activity and just a tested
to see if it was some other factor in
the plasma or these particles
he removed the particles and then saw
that the activity was no longer there so
he showed in these experiments that the
by activity was associated with need
with these particles themselves now
despite the fact that this is very
interesting very interesting results and
observations not which was done after
1967 until 1983 when work was being done
at doctor stalls lab by Harding and
others that studying the transferrin
cycle and so the transferrin cycle is
research looking at the recycling of
iron binding blood plasma glycoproteins
using reticulocytes and immature blood
cells looking at the iron receptor
complex more in these complexes form
endosomal membrane set the cell at the
plasma membrane and are internalized and
are converted to multi vesicular bodies
which are essentially exosomes
what eventually become exosomes and so
they're recycled back out releasing
their contents into the extracellular
space as exosomes and here you can see
from their work couple of micro graphs
will you see the multi the circular
bodies and you see also their fusion and
release plasma membrane where ultimately
here you see a vesicle on the surface of
the reticulocyte and these are labeled
with gold particles and so that's how
you're able to so this is one of the if
not the very first observation and the
mechanism by which they are exterior
lines and so a brief timeline now which
includes a little bit of we already
spoke of so 1957 apparently was a period
when multi vesicular bodies were being
studied but at this time I don't think
anybody knew or even frustrated that
they were exteriorized at least not as
functional entities further than maybe
in epic five bodies in 1967 that's
Wolf's work where you identified the
platelet test and then in 1983 there's a
Hardeen install work with the multi
particular buttons and in 1987 Ron
Johnson which also was working in 1983
and so on on multi the sick of the body
she's the one that is credited with
giving or coming up with the X's own
terminology very important people was
published in 1987 by Grasso
and others which is working at with
antigen presenting cells and she found
that dendritic cells produced extra
zones and that these extra somes
expressed MHC 1 and MHC 2 molecules that
they induced and enhanced antigen
specific T cell response in an e-book so
this was one of those seminal papers and
in O two a industry group
comprising needs to individuals dr.
Karen dr. epic were the first as far as
I know to create the combin int X isms
and to use them and postulate their use
for immune as new modulators as
therapeutics among many other uses for
them including the drug delivery in 2003
and 2005 again dr. Johnston working now
more fully in the field decided to
promote and establish the first meeting
on exosomes and around that same period
this is when I got involved in the field
with the group led by dr. Chris cough
ski in 2004 and 2005 and our group was
the first to identify exosomes and
extracellular vesicle RNA and DNA
carbons and also to identify coding and
regulatory on her knee and their
horizontal transfer in 2006 an academic
group led by dr. rata check confirmed
these findings and also showed
reprogramming using RNA horizontal
transfer and then in 2007 dr. Volare and
dr. lavro
also confirmed these prior results and
extended the known number of entities
that that the exorcisms carried actually
they created a very large list of mRNA
and MI RNA sequences that they found in
in exosomes and show vesicles and they
also confirmed the RNA transfer and in
2008 scogan they trailed kind of Boston
also confirmed that work further in in
disease video blastoma and they also
identified and confirmed RNA transfer
associated with and then very exciting
to me because I come from the
preclinical field day in 2012 Liu and
dr. wood of Oxford
were able to produce recombinant
exosomes and and show delivery in vivo
so they injected IV these recombinant
exosomes that were loaded with various
markers and RNA I type therapeutics and
they were able to show delivery to
specific brain cells across the
blood-brain barrier which I think it's
putting a pretty significant so it says
to 2010 we see an exponential growth of
interest in the field and of academic
papers being published over 1,700 papers
were published during those last 3 to 5
years and also the International Society
for extrasolar vesicles was formed and
there's over 700 scientists and
academics involved so most of most of
this interest is from academia but more
and more nowadays there's interest from
from other groups including commercial
and industry groups by the way a select
bio has published several reports
they've been following this field very
closely for a while and if you're
interested in looking at various
publications broken down a lot of detail
as to the specific biomarkers that they
were looking at or we're looking at a
text storms or like vesicles or their
applications we're looking at RNA or
protein content these reports break it
down very closely and they also have
other reports on the field in general
very interestingly the National
Institutes of Health have taken an
interest in this field as well and they
have coined the term X RNA to describe
it don't know the return they also are
designated a common fund project and my
understanding that this is sort of a
privileged designation
and it's reserved for very special
circumstances and projects and so I
think they do a very good job of sort of
representing how special this field is
in order to qualify for this designation
it has to be a unique area of research
that has a transformative potential that
is very catalytic and that is
synergistic with for their areas of
research and other technologies and it's
cross-cutting and indeed I think the if
we don't all agree yet perhaps after a
few more slides here we might all agree
that that certainly exosomes and if
similar vesicles fall within that
definition so go now a little bit to
their physiology and development in
pathology and particularly in human
disease and so they are interestingly
very concerned very concerned across
very divergent species and so the I
think this is a sign that it's that they
are essentially a very fundamental
phenomenon and of course most of the
work is done in mammalians murine models
nowadays but they're also they've been
identified in bacteria and implant and
in parasites and in developmental
biology they've been identified and had
been referred to as morph engine so
after quite some time and so this is
interesting some of our early work was a
stem cell so it makes sense that they
had been looked at but again the
extracellular vesicles is terminology
that's fairly recent but they've been
known for as many many different things
including as referred to earlier as dust
particles or micro particles
microvesicles when I got involved and
then stones as a subset and they're also
referred to by their tissue of origins
where those processes ohms and then
there's dec systems for those that are
derived
dendritic cells and many many other
names including chromosomes interesting
today there they are found in all major
biological fluids as far as I know I
don't know that there's been any
anywhere they haven't been found and so
it includes blood fractions a serum and
plasma and urine saliva cerebral spinal
fluid even in breast milk and ascites
and synovial fluid in the semen and
sweat and tears and there were some
talks yes you did that covered saliva
research so in pathology
they've been implicated in myriad of
diseases those include diabetes
cardiovascular disease and many
neurological diseases including
Alzheimer's Parkinson's multiple
sclerosis and also in various podium
autoimmune conditions like rheumatoid
arthritis lupus
they've also in prenatal research
they've been DNA and RNA has been
identified in microvesicles that come
from embryonic maternal blood and so
these could have potential applications
and fetal genetic mutation analysis I
know there's been some publications that
even sex-toy embryos and using exons and
they've been used in research in
preeclampsia in oncology hematology is a
big area where they've been identified
and and are involved in various
pathogenic events they are also being
used by a group to develop Diagnostics
and it's expected that those those tests
might be released in the next year or so
they also have been involved in almost
every solid cancer type including those
listed here and in metastatic
as well which is really important when
you're talking about trying to
understand and prevent or reduce
mortality in patients as metastasis is
the the biggest source of that a
fundamental importance is their
horizontal transfer of their contents
and most interest for us is its their
RNA and transfer and so these molecules
act as a shuttle system delivering
bioactive molecules whether it's by
Langan ligand receptor interactions or
taken up by endocytosis or the effusion
with plasma membranes so they the
transfer it can can induce
transformation of the recipient cell in
a certain thing you affect phenotype and
they affect growth division
differentiation
stress response survival apoptosis and
many many other things and a lot of
these functions are published works in
those seventeen plus hundred
publications that are out there and so I
won't go into a lot of the activities
that have been published related to this
but we're gonna be a little bit short on
time a lot to cover but but certainly
I'd be happy to send you the cause and
references and links if you're
interested there's a bit of a dichotomy
in that they're involved in normal
physiology there's and also in disease
and so with stem cells they can modulate
phenotype and as I mentioned earlier
then identified as morphogens
in developmental biology an immune
response
you know they carry inflammatory
molecules and are involved in antigen
presentation and then the nervous system
they carry neuro protective factors and
they act as trophic support for
excellence and then on the on the right
side of things you know in cancer as
mentioned earlier they they are
involved in growth invasion and
metastasis and in neurodegeneration they
can spread pathologic characteristics to
other regions of the brain and that the
scene in cancer as well again in there
they're involved in many different
disease mechanisms and in particular
here there's examples from their
involvement in cancer and so this these
are activities or functions that they
found in tumor derived microvesicles and
some of them are I'll go through them
very quickly but it's modulation of the
micro environments for tumor growth
horizontal transfer of edge FM mRNAs and
promotion of angiogenesis evasion and
immune surveillance cloaking of tumor
cells from the immune system in invasion
and metastasis they carry protease
cargos of facilitate matrix degeneration
and also in the transfer of aggressive
phenotypes to horizontal transfer of
oncogenic receptors and Arnie multi-drug
resistance to influx from cells and
again there's there's a lot more
information that could be discussed that
if you're interested let me know I'll
send you some links and some references
immune they're also very involved in
immune function in particular those
related to tumor Genesis and so this
light here I'll just read off from notes
here but it's basically exercise
released from tumor cells effective
focal tumor environment remodeling
extracellular matrix and promoting
vascular genesis and tumor cell
formations they can travel to distant
sites to promote the generation of pre
metastatic niches and vascular zation is
augmented and endothelial and stromal
cell differentiation is induced leading
to pro tumor environment and immune
responses they become the immune
responses can become deregulated in a
manner that impedes tumor recognition
and anti-tumor immune
with cytotoxic T cells induced apoptosis
where in case that proliferation is
impaired in T cells differentiate or the
T regulatory cell phenotype and in bone
marrow drive cells can be recruited to
the tumor and pre to leticia where they
contribute to cancer development and so
as we can see they're involved in a
myriad of different physiological and
pathological functions and so that makes
them a very interesting entities to
study but also because they are
available in the circulation and these
entities can be interrogated and studied
they are also powerful tools for
research and powerful for drug
development we think and also for
molecular diagnostics so we think it's a
it's a very infertile environment at the
moment from and I think this is because
there's been a confluence of key
technologies and developments that have
that have come along and so you know
perhaps ten years ago was a bit more
difficult to proceed it that that they
would have such a huge impact but now
that these developments from the fourth
I think it's much easier to predict that
that they would have a transforming
effect on on research and on and
treating the human diseases so the
fertile environment and I think is very
synergistic with v's in particular for
precision medicine and basically just
the quick summary I'm sure everybody is
aware of this but you know it's it's are
moved from to a molecular basis for
disease and the identification of
molecular and gene errors and in the
development of molecular interventions
to correct them so leading to customize
and engine individualized treatment and
this is of course represented by the
dozens of targeted therapeutics and
companion diagnostics that they'd been
developed for cancer and other diseases
and although there there has been huge
advances most diseases and most
conditions are not yet on the treatment
of targeted therapeutics
the list as you can see there were these
little but commonly and targeted
therapeutics is on the market approved
now but about 42% is estimated the
current drugs and development are now
targeted therapeutics and that number is
expected to increase as is the absolute
number of drugs that will be put in the
future so it could be hundreds of drugs
in the next 10 20 years and also
important developments in the next
generation sequencing and informatics
and in other Olmec style technology is
very important so sequencing of the
human genome of course has propelled
this whole field an area nowadays the
cost of exilim and whole genome
sequencing has dropped quite a bit and
through product is higher and the
bioinformatics available and data mining
capabilities are moving very quickly and
of course other omics technologies are
developing quickly to me and may catch
up soon and these are all applicable to
me of course precision medicine but in
particular and our interest is in
analyzing exosomes
whether it's for research or molecular
diagnostics and so among these other
technologies are transcriptomics
proteomics lipid omics and metabolomics
and so these as we mentioned earlier
since exorcisms are carriers of a lot of
these molecules that would be amenable
to this type of analysis it's it's very
exciting to see this technology
developing and becoming accessible in
terms of the costs and also improvements
in in their sensitivity there's also a
renewed interest in the ultimen what I
believe is the ultimate in personalized
medicine which is the use of the immune
system to do the work for us and so neo
antigens are hot and there's
applications for exorcisms in their
field
in many many ways and so as we all
probably agree that diseases is really a
dynamic and relational event set of
events and it's constantly evolving I
think that again extracellular vesicles
and exosomes ideal for this these
developments and for combination with
these other technologies so here's just
a representation of the various
fashionable genetic changes that have
been identified and then the drugs that
are available for those to treat those
and again that repertoire is growing
quickly and will be very large and so I
think exosomes can can one help to
monitor for disease monitor patients but
also to help identify new markers and
even therapeutics is so easy and
exosomes are uniquely positioned to
catalyze change and particularly for
diseases therapeutic response monitoring
and we think that they will allow us to
move from extrapolation to
individualized approach and so further
the move to personalized medicine and
move us from an invasive to minimum
invasive techniques and processes and
from a static to a dynamic approach and
as well as from single to relational
holistic analysis various factors and of
course all this will help us to be more
proactive instead of reactive by being
able to monitor even before disease and
during disease and during treatment and
as the technology becomes more precise
and the scale down miniaturized as well
as costs are reduced there are already
plans to develop point of care units
that can do excellent and for sequencing
analysis and so over the next 20 years I
think this will be in common
and so now we're gonna move into
specific applications and I think we're
the the the value can really be gained
from from this technology is in the
research and development continuum
excuse me and here what we're gonna do
is we're gonna cover a bit of a case
study which is found Island
pharmaceuticals as an example of what
can be done with this technology and so
basically we think that exercise and
mcvish goals would make incredible
actually they have been used as a
platform for pharmaceutical molecular
diagnostic development and I think they
can support every phase of that
development including basic research
biomarker discovery screening and
targeting new targets preclinical
efficacy absolutely and preclinical
safety also in clinical safety in
toxicology to monitor clinical response
there's a lot of work being done now and
translational research and development
of bio signatures but beyond being used
as tools they can actually be used to
develop new drug delivery systems and
gene delivery systems and identifying
with therapeutic targets and actually
function as its therapies and as imaging
agents so moving on to to the case study
so Long Island pharmaceuticals they are
a pharmaceutical company which is
developing gene modulation for
pharmaceuticals and their focus is
basically in small interfering RNA and
they have a delivery system which we
won't get into here so our interest is
and exercise but they also in in their
development programs you can study micro
RNA antisense all the goals and viral
vectors as as methods of delivering
therapeutics and so that's is this is
very nice because they they've used this
these various modalities using hex
and so it's a very strong and robust
principle that we'll see here and so in
doing this research it requires quite a
bit of monitoring of tissue specific
gene modulation which means that in vivo
you essentially have sacrificing animals
and exercise the tissues and run various
staining and processes to to do the
analysis of gene modulation and so it's
it's difficult it's like consuming and
it's very costly and of course in humans
if not impossible it would be very
limiting and so the idea or monitoring
system would be one that is not invasive
and temporarily you could use across
various stages of development and
ideally with the same animal you don't
want to have different cohorts of
animals to evaluate different time
points so having the same animal as its
own control is also a huge advantage
which of course is also an application
in humans and of course you would want
to see close correlation with tissue
gene expression and you would want it to
translate against against or across
different models of disease different
species and into the clinical demons and
so I'm happy to say that they certainly
have shown this that it's a it's a very
good platform and they just to go back a
little bit they use the sort of standard
method of isolating exercise they used
serum from animals but also from
patients and they filtered and then used
a little spin to get remove the cells
and debris then they knew
self-certification for a few hours and
then they extracted the RNA and I'll
analyze their target the key pieces are
and so in their case most of the
research prior to using exosomes
required
tissue and I'm sure they use it in
parallel but but yeah it required a lot
more animals
we're working on more spins now in in
some of their studies they have
conditions where they can follow the
condition using circulating secreted
proteins but in cases where those four
things are not available the value of
exercise would be and and something you
were you could track gene expression
from peripheral blood or other fluids
would be tremendous
and so they've shown that that they
could they could follow their targets in
various bodily fluids using mRNA as
their source material and so they've
shown that exercise can be used to
monitor RNA mechanisms in the
circulation and again they mentioned
that it would be valuable where the
proteins on there will circulate
inclusions and so they here's the one of
many datasets that they show and I
recommend that you look up there this
poster many of the people I've spoken to
are not aware of this so anyway the they
showed very close correlation and
there's a color experiment in that they
run and and be and they ran the
experiments a time course rat liver
tissues versus exosome derived mRNA so
they treated these these rats using attr
silencing LMP si RNA therapeutic and
they injected the animals tightly and
you can see the close correlation the
the black is the tissue and green are
the serum levels of expression and the
first experiment this is done over a
period of days from day one to day 14
and they basically are looking at the
recovery downregulated genes whereas an
experiment B they're looking at earlier
time points so they're looking at hours
and looking at the initial effect and
again the correlation was was very very
strong now that's in animal models but
they moved on to use the same technology
in Phase one clinical study using this
target the trance directing little
voices or TTR for short and it's a
neurodegenerative disease and mid
affects the deliver and amyloid deposits
or really the pathology that is fatal to
patients that have this condition and so
they used a gene silencing RNA
therapeutic to target the tissues in the
liver and some and they monitored this
liver down regulation using exosomes and
so they use TTR mrna the key of its
product as their marker and there's
potential to use this technology for
therapeutic activity monitoring as well
as potential to customize dose safety
evaluations and so this is published in
the New England Journal of Medicine and
as their VP of research states they use
this as critical points in their for
development process and here's a
reported data on their use in the phase
one study where you know our interest
they they showed very good data
very good effects which is great but our
interest is that fact that they use the
RNA eye mechanism to confirm mechanism
of action they used analysis of
circulating mRNA they also use this in a
another study so that shows that it's
again very robust and they used it
interesting both consumed and in urine
and they saw very similar results to
the other previous phase one study and
they it it also reflects the data that
they shown all the data that they
generated in Bieber within Viva models
so conclusion I think that it's a it's a
very robust platform it translates well
across various species across
therapeutic time course and also across
the various therapeutic modalities that
they use so they evaluated this in vitro
and mouse rat non-human primates and
human tears and they showed Burston
correlations there you know they did it
over in ours and they also studied it
over a period of days which I think goes
fifty days and then they they used it
using various therapeutic modalities
like SSI RNA mRNA anta sense and
congenial gene therapies and they saw a
very good good results so I think this
is a very good argument that this
technology it worked well for them but
it has a potential to work almost any
therapeutic development program and
there's big interest from us we are
working on on various projects that are
taking into account but beyond the
research and development phases they
have applications across the whole
disease and treatment Continuum's and so
at least in in monitoring and in
diagnosis you know they could be used
and publications have shown that they
could be used to show predisposition for
conditions as well as constraining
diagnosis prognosis as well as
monitoring for treatment and also
monitoring for drug resistance and
relapse and beyond that they they also
there are programs to develop them as
diagnostic imaging reagents
and as I mentioned earlier they can also
be used as to identify new therapeutic
targets or to use them as I started to
towards delivery vehicles and also in
immunotherapy and tumor vaccine type
strategies so now I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna move into are sort of seminal
experiments and in our early work is an
example molecular diagnostic
applications and so the premise here is
that tissue is the issue and I borrowed
this from another presentation could be
pretty mixed around but anyway the
tissue is absolutely the both standard
and it's how we diagnose the most most
conditions including cancer but it does
have many limitations among those are
limited sample availability that the
biopsy or tissue that is obtained
typically represents a single point in
time it also represents a small region
of the lesion unless it's a full
surgical resection and that petition may
you may have representation even within
within a tumor it's been found that at
different regions of the tumors have
different different characteristics so
your representation that a tumor may be
eliminating the other thing is that if
that if you're looking at invasive
cancer you may not be representing those
areas where the tumor has migrated or
even in metastasis which is of course
the most important for survival but it's
also invasive as as a procedure and it
can be risky for the patient it's
expensive and there's no possibility for
continuous monitoring and there's no
possibility for individualized baselines
or bio signatures using tissue whereas
with liquid biopsy style you know
exersaucer vesicle vesicles you could
potentially use them to the begin
monitoring
individuals way before disease presents
itself and to me that that would be sort
of a dream projects to take no 10
and individuals and start monitoring
them now and begin to create that data
set and to see where the disease arises
and where the triggers anyway the the
2004 our hypothesis was that we could
use the extra solar vesicles to to move
again this is a little bit of a recap
with extrapolation to individualized
approach from an invasive to a
non-invasive approach from a static to a
dynamic approach and from a single to
relational holistic analysis and of
course that all that would potentially
eight being more proactive rather than
reactive and as the cost reduce or
reduced to move from lab to care systems
and so this is a real paradigm change
that's underway and it's moving us from
what I like to say it's a static picture
in a situation to a moving picture
situation so the traditional tissue
approach and we're using her to as a
model because we really work so we as I
mentioned before we were the first
discovery of the Association RNA and DNA
and Envy's and so we we selected her to
as a model basically because it's very
well characterized and at the time there
was already a therapeutic and a
companion diagnostic and there was quite
a bit of research that was being done in
this particular field so I thought it
would be a great model to to test our
hypothesis on so in tissue again this is
this is the tissue the standard is to do
and you know it's the chemistry for self
soft surface receptors and when there's
a question as to whether the results for
affirmative or not then they move on to
fish which is a gene copy analysis of by
fluorescence in situ hybridization
interestingly though there's plenty of
work off some publications on on PCR
this particular hurt to nominee and
there's also the protein is soluble so
you can be found
the extracellular space and so there was
an Eliza did all feel that although we
never I don't think it was developed
into a clinical test this at least
successful commercially but anyway so so
it creates a very nice platform to to
use for benchmarking and so a little bit
more just background on her to just so
what's the experiments on in context so
her two is a human epidermal growth
factor receptor to huncle protein and
twenty to thirty percent of all breast
cancer cases are positive for her to
with it being the second poorest
prognosis for patients so it's a very
serious condition Herceptin was a
humanized anti her two monoclonal
antibody that was developed by the way
there's a book called I think what
believe it's called her2 which is very
good what goes into the whole
development history on this it's very
interesting anyway the patient's there
was a companion diagnostic that was
developed in conjunction and so you have
to be positive for her to under that
companion diagnostic in order to be
eligible to treatment
unfortunately only about thirty percent
of those patients that are eligible
respond and the average extension life
is about nine months and this is on mono
thirty I'm sure there been improvements
since then and there are new therapies
that target other variants of for two
but also there's a acquired resistance
which is a huge farm and it's one more
recognizing again those new therapeutics
and another a combination therapies of
or addressing that but it there's still
a huge opportunity for new technologies
that can identify new markers in new
methods of monitoring the patient's for
resistance and trying to capture it
early as early as possible there's also
the fact that some of these tumors are
evolving so being able to identify other
potential targets for therapeutics is
very important and so that's for the
whole
profiling tumor profiling comes in and
ideally being done in liquid form the
best here's how you score the tumors and
this is important because they use these
standard cell lines
sko v3 as a high expressing her to a
clone MD and be 2/3 so you can see it so
well but anyway and 247d and mcf-7 so
that's the the gold standard MHC new
host of chemistry and here's the
micrographs and the different levels and
so again a score of 2 or score of 1 is
considered typical and so it has to go
to needle fluorescence and importantly
again these these cell lines are used as
controls in actual clinical testing so
they are very important this is a fish
which is the fluorescence in situ
hybridisation where they actually just
do a G camp so if you get a gene count
the time into then you're considered
positive so here's our first our first
experiment and this is very early on but
again we what we did is we used those
Saints Airlines used in vitro and then
the first chart here on the left shows
the expression levels of the different
lines in cells themselves and so this is
an expected results where the SK will be
is is quite elevated compared to the
other two which are negative so we did
the same experiment well using the media
the cell media and the x1 was extracted
from that and so we could see that the
results are very similar and correlate
and then we also did some hydro gel
electrophoresis to confirm those results
and you can see here that the
expressions there and also relative SK
over 3 expresses it quite high compared
to the other the evidence so of course
being in in preclinical research I know
that a lot of times when East Indian
Beach for those
so translates people so we moved on to a
pilot study using xenograft models and
these basically used the high-level
expressiveness catering three cells so
we injected these in and if I make a
move mice let the tumor grow till it was
palpable and then it took mice that were
not bearing tumors and we tested the
serum from those mice and again we saw
that the expression was very high and
those that are carrying the tumor and
the ones that weren't did not express by
the way these are human tumors so these
are human tumors being expressed in mice
so there was a very good indication that
that this could work in human soon and
so there are a very next experiment was
was in in using clinical samples and so
we obtained frozen samples from biobank
and we obtained samples that had been
identified as positive by
immunohistochemistry and so they were
known positive cases and we have here
compared to normal controls so
individuals without cancer at all and so
you see that there's there's definitely
a stark difference between the two
groups using PCR the groups that were
positive they were of note there was the
number five is a stage two and number
four is six or stage one so that's a
there was an early indication that you
could do identify and so the advantages
and and we think this is a potential
game-changer is because the the analysis
of exosomes beyond you know using a
single marker like we did in those
experiments that can be math
multifactorial so you could look at
various RNAs
not a single one and indeed most of the
work now is looking at bio signatures of
multiple mRNAs mRNAs the also
multifactorial in the sense that there
different categories of markers are in a
DNA and lipids and protein markers and
so all these can be used together the
proteins to isolate subpopulations we
could look for gene alterations in DNA
or gene expression using RNA protein
expression we can also identify the cell
of origin based on on cell markers or
even the markers that are associated
with cancer and isolate folks so there's
there's a potential here for very
relational analysis using transform
makes proteomics genomics and mitso
aseye possibly is reduced these can be
used now for research but as the cost is
reduced you can see that this
potentially could be used so again to
use the phrase again so we would be
moving from a static snapshot to to
moving pictures and so going to a
minimally invasive approach you're using
bio fluids a dynamic approach because we
could be able to do limit their sampling
and real-time monitoring as well as more
personalized approach since we would be
looking at biomarkers and bio signatures
for that specific individual also
personally says that we could establish
baselines for an individual and then
it's relational we could using various
lumic technologies and potentially you
know we could follow the individual or a
full lifecycle from conception to a
geriatrics and that would be ideal so I
think that's that's what the feature
that we're looking at Ron synergistic
with existing and emerging technologies
and so in conclusion so what is the
future and what some of the future
challenges and actually this is inspired
by a talk that I that I heard by Mustafa
Brody of this was the chief technology
officer at Illumina and teams talking
about how complexity increases with
disease progression
and and I fully agree and this is my
representation of that and so as we move
from a hemostasis standard in health to
certain critical events that we may or
may not be aware of that then lead to
complex network this regulation and as
we move further into those needs and so
right now I see it as you know the far
right when we're identifying
dysregulation or markers that are
already in you know in a complex disease
sort of environment whereas I think the
ideal situation would be to de certeau
the but the film on rewind and go find
the the points critical events which
this regulation really really started
and I think that's that's to me that's
the that's the Holy Grail and I hope
that that's where we're moving to in the
future so so we we don't currently
understand these critical events what
where and when did the driver
alterations occur so we know that these
are time dependent events and they're
patient specific and they're relational
and so ideally we'd like to so that the
question is you know do we do monitoring
of genomic alterations or gene
expression and I think we have to do
both and we have to do it early and we
have to do it across the life cycle so
V's and X or exercise may be the key to
have because they have all the
characteristics necessary to address
this challenge and so far they're active
frontiers or the application of v's and
exercise and this could be for other
toxin there are other groups that are
working very deeply in this as fast as
we are with various collaborators but
definitely an biomarker discovery and
therapeutic target discovery targeted
drug delivery immunotherapy and in
regenerative medicine and to end the
talk here these are just a few of the
companies that are delving into this
field either just looking to see what's
there or actually many of them have
advanced political development projects
that are underway with some of them
being schedules can be commercialized in
the next maybe by the end of this year
early next year so anyway thank you and
now we'll move on to any questions so
there's a question here about
preeclampsia and micro rna's and I know
that there's work already in that field
so and I'm not privy to the data there
but but I would encourage you to look
those those up so but Dad there's
definitely work being done down there by
other groups
thank you Ray for bringing that
important presentation to us but is just
about all the time we have for questions
I know you did read that question that
was in there was very long and complex
but we will definitely follow up if we
didn't have time to get to your question
today where I want to thank everybody
for logging in and just pass it back to
Ray for any final comments that he has
for our audience in its nascent stages
and so I look forward to being involved
and engaged with all of you in the
future and thanks again and thanks again
Brenda for hosting
you're very welcome rate was good
information we had hear from you today I
just want to let our audience know that
this presentation will be on demand
available on our website through October
2016 you'll be receiving an email from
lab roots letting you know when that
webcast is available for replay and we
would invite you to forward that email
to any colleagues who may have missed
today's live presentation that's all for
now we hope we see you again here at lab
roots thank you so much and goodbye